good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday that
feels like a monday because it's tuesday
after a long weekend hope everyone had
an amazing laborious day weekend hey jax
how you doing doing good cause it's a
short week can't wait it was a great
long holiday weekend i know you had a
great jam-packed weekend as well
probably a little more exciting than
mine but we don't need to compare we
don't no i agree we are women who do not
compare other women ever we are women
who support each other's holiday
weekends no matter we support each
other's endeavors always
always am forever yes i just returned
from turks and caicos last night
i had the most incredible weekend like
not to be so annoying
um first of all like i just forgot about
turks and caicos as like a potential
vacation destination and if you live on
the east coast it does feel like you
know when you compare east coast to west
coast
people who live in la like they have so
many better options you know they're so
close to mexico it's literally a
45-minute flight they have hawaii like
we have like florida and then the east
coast of mexico which is not as fun as
the west coast east coast of mexico
isn't as fun but then we have the
caribbean and we have the bahamas and we
have turks and caicos we have dominican
river right right right of costa rica so
i totally just forgot about turks and
caicos because we've only been one time
we went together um and first of all can
i just say i don't even want to like say
positive things because i don't want
anyone to go because it's like i think
it's like a great kept secret but it's
so
fast literally the flight there was two
hours and 52 minutes it was so easy the
way back the airport is
a [ __ ] show like it was one of the
lowest points of my life like just being
hungover depressed that my trip was over
sweating my [ __ ] tits off
sun
sunburn but it was worth it i'm a little
constipated you know the classic you
can't go on a trip without getting
constipated but
all in all totally worth it i had the
best time i went with like the best
group of people um it was like a family
trip because i had ben and obviously
counselor snitch was also like a
friend's trip because brian and taylor
and taylor and john so it was just
incredible like it was so much fun it
was a combination of like truly relaxing
while also like lit you know we got to
explore we were doing adventurous things
but also relaxing it was
i have absolutely no regrets about my
decision which is just a great feeling
that's so great was it so hot there
so technically it's the off season
because it's their rainy season so
that's why it was like not empty but
very very like low-key which i
appreciate it so much like there's
nothing i hate more than going on
vacation when like it's busy you know um
and it literally didn't rain it rained
for 10 minutes one day and we like
happened to be eating lunch inside and
then we came back out and it was fine
i'm not worried about the rain because
like we get rainstorms here and i guess
you know it's the off season also in
florida but i'm like it's so hot here is
it even hotter there
um it was hot yeah but like it's not
it's like vacation hot you know you
appreciate the hotter it is the better
it's not like i have to live and go to
work like in the heat that is horrible
yeah but like when you're out on the
beach are you dying
no it's so breezy like so so breezy
that's gorgeous
it was amazing we had this great house
like it was so incredible i have like a
newfound love and respect for turks and
caicos i like having not a new found but
just a re um reinstated love of my
friends like it was such a great group
and it was just a
it was such an interesting vibe
obviously like i have different groups
of friends and i don't think i've ever
really been on a proper vacation with
this group as a whole
um
and it's like the level of comfortable i
felt in front of these people like
obviously you know there's always a
level of discomfort when you're in a
bathing suit in front of other people
um and i just really didn't have that
and i also like you know on a group trip
there's like a lot of pressure like
always be doing stuff like
group trips can be extremely [ __ ]
treacherous well it also depends what
kind of travelers you're with you could
have your best friend in the world but
if they want to go to museums and go
sightseeing and you want to lay at the
beach like it's just not going to be a
good trip if they want to wake up and do
pilates like we're just not on the same
level even if they're you're so
simpatico him not to go ironical you
would share your deepest darkest secrets
with them if they're waking up and doing
yoga lotties it's not a it's not gonna
work
so everyone was really on the same page
i was just like i had such a great time
i'm so happy i went i got tan which is
just
it's an incomparable feeling to be tan
even if it's i guess my lips are like
literal raisins they're so chapped right
now and sunburn i don't even care the
confidence that a tan gives you is so
insurmountable and
try as you may like a fake tan is great
but it's never gonna be a real tan
and there's nothing that can boost your
confidence more
than a tan a real tan did you wear
sunscreen i did i did
did snitch
yes yes we all did like the first day we
were like [ __ ] it and a few hours in we
were like we have to put on some blocks
because we weren't wearing sunscreen we
were lathering up but there it was
useless it was a fruitless endeavor
but you need to you can't just raw dog
it so close to the equator in august no
no no no you can't and we didn't but um
we're still all like pretty burned my
nose is starting to peel it's like my
least favorite part of going on vacation
coming back like a crusty girl but the
crustiness reminds you of the good times
that were shared right like every time i
see like on my pillow a little flake of
dead skin i'm like oh brian john
taylor taylor
yeah um how was your weekend my weekend
was good it was i was here i mean i
guess every day is a vacation when you
live in florida um not that i like spend
time outside or when in my pool or
anything i haven't been in my pool since
you were here but it was really nice i
was low-key and fun and family-oriented
and i got to read and watch a little tv
i'm all caught up on southern charm
and it was good i ate a lot
i saw you um
taking a selfie with a martini in your
hand and i think we should talk about it
okay what do you want to say about it
you had a martini no and you know that i
didn't
i know but like i wanted you to have a
martini she's calling me out so hard i
sent a selfie and i also posted it to my
instagram where i'm holding a martini
but um the truth is that it was zack's
martini and i was holding it because i
thought it looked cool for a photo the
martini looks cool in the photo i looked
like a woolly mammoth
oh my god we have to talk like my
weekend was obviously consumed by my
vacation but like the last 36 hours have
been
consumed by venice film festival like if
you would have told me last week like or
not last week like last year claudia
like next year you're gonna be obsessed
with the venice film festival i would
have been like what changed you know i i
couldn't be bothered to care about these
film festivals like ever um but wow
between the brendan fraser sadie sink of
it all of course the don't worry darling
extreme
awkwardness i am
hooked but then there's also like there
was a
boat a gondola where chase stokes
sydney sweeney
armani beauty
mendez
yeah the hits kept coming and they don't
stop coming yes our armani beauty like
is perhaps like a sponsor of the venice
film festival and they basically did
like a revolve around the world but with
like really premium young hollywood like
the the who's who the it girls and boys
of young hollywood and they've been just
taking photos mod apatow was there it is
this gorgeous group of gorgeous people
doing gorgeous things and while i did
live for every minute of it i also like
i really just kind of highlighted what a
disgusting slob i am like the fact like
it was just it was too much it was too
glamorous did you see sabrina carpenter
there having a little moment for herself
these days with her new album and her
look at the vmas and then she wore
that head to toe valentino pink barbie
outfit that anne hathaway wore
and
without being rude it looked i preferred
it without without being ageist yeah i
preferred it on sabrina
okay i did not see sabrina carpenter
there but i love that you brought up the
moment moment sabrina carpenter is
currently having i'm so happy for her
happy for her her album is popping off
everyone is obsessed with it she's been
looking gorgeous red carpet red carpet
red carpet bus club another club bus
no sleep
i'm so happy for her she bangs she
deserves it
she deserves it she's been through a lot
and i'm really happy for her i
personally have been following sabrina
carpenter for like 10 years now
and
i'm so happy to see that she's finally
having the moment and people are
experiencing her in the way that i've
been enjoying for 10 years you know
yeah i've been like following sabrina
carpenter since that song came out that
was the theme song to her um show on my
channel
what was that song it was [ __ ]
amazing
i don't know
oh well i loved that song like when i
was an intern at aol i was listening to
it all the time like yeah that's it's
funny how music like especially like as
it relates to work you associate
different songs with like different jobs
yeah and her first album is so good
she's an extremely talented queen and of
course a lot of that was eclipsed
momentarily by the olivia rodrigo of it
all but now i feel like she's getting
her you know individuality back and for
that i'm happy her new song i saw she
performed on one of the jimmies it's
called like because i liked a boy have
you heard it because i like to bow
and it's about the saga how she's you
know jessie yeah all this crap all
because she's like
yeah like not even like a special one he
was literally a boy
just a boy like very regular like boy
boy
um so we're gonna get into venice
obviously
like on the plane yesterday i was like
shaya
shayashaya
miss flow miss fluff i'm obsessed with
the saga and of course like all eyes are
on the don't worry darling premiere um
so every little video every snippet is
like people are blowing it up like
looking in they think you know harry
styles spit on chris pine we'll get into
all of it i just want to say like
knowing that
everyone's eyes are on them i feel like
they really really tried to like not
make anything a story other than the
movie and in their efforts are acting so
[ __ ] bizarre robotic and
it's making the whole situation even
weirder
yes i agree i think that they were all
extremely well behaved but like so
almost to the point that it's unnatural
no they were so fake and honestly
they're bad actors so how could the
movie be good
[Music]
the acting is um bad ooh
hot taste take
take
um
so i really don't like have much else to
catch up on um because literally all i
want to do is talk about don't worry
darling so if there's anything else i
read another christina lauren book that
was recommended oh you recommended the
on honeymooners no i've always had that
on my want to read this but i never read
it take it off take it off okay
take it off
i finished priscilla presley's memoir
oh elvis and me and it was really good
and if you do want more info about elvis
i would watch it because i'm sorry i
would read it because it gives you a lot
of elvis factoids a lot of priscilla i
feel like i got the picture
there's obviously more to elvis before
priscilla and after priscilla but they
were together for
more than 10 years so
there's also the linda thompson of it
all the bertie jenner's mom of it all
which um i didn't really realize that
she had dated
elvis um and that's because i don't
follow her on instagram because every
other photo she posts on instagram is
about elvis it's a picture of her and
elvis um i didn't know any of that but
apparently her book is also quite quite
juicy but it's like
am i trying to be mean i just feel like
when i was looking under social media
it's like no matter how many chanel bags
you borrow you will never be lisa marie
like she thinks like she's the girl
elvis it's like it's
it's lisa oh sorry
it's priscilla sorry yeah i agree but
linda thompson although has an
incredibly interesting life i think her
book is interesting on its own if you're
going there for the elvis tea i don't
think it's going to be priscilla's but
linda thompson was just like that woman
she caught every man every man i also
think i was trying to figure it out when
i was looking on her instagram i do
believe she was with elvis when he died
no not physically but dating no
according to priscilla's book linda was
with elvis for four years priscilla
thought that she was good for him and
then he started dating he was dating a
woman named ginger for a few months and
and that and i think she was the
girlfriend the last one he passed yeah
okay because i was trying to figure it
out she was like when i found out i was
at graceland i'm like wait so
she might have been at graceland you
know
still a member of the the family and the
family yeah the friend group it was like
a big friend group
also netflix dropped the trailer today
for
lucky's girl alive um which is as you
guys know jackie and i's favorite book
we found out a while ago that mila kunis
was going to be reprising the role of
any connie fanelli ani finnelli and the
trailer came out i didn't realize or
maybe i just didn't like care to look
that it was going to be a netflix movie
or like as opposed to being in a theater
um i love when they make it easy for us
because i can watch it
when it comes out not six months later
like elvis
um and i just want to say like one
negative thing
um
like the trailer was just giving
community theater vibes like that's all
i'll say but you really can't tell a
movie by the trailer like you can't
judge a book by its cover i was just
getting kind of like low budget energy
from the acting
oh that's weird
that's just me i wasn't i feel like it's
got they're going to pull out all the
stops
i know just like when mila kunis was
narrating she's like i'm getting married
in a lavish but tasteful wedding like it
was just kind of cringey that's so annie
it didn't just kind of cringe i didn't
get that at all honestly
i i i'm so excited it looks perfect i
think it's really well cast i hope they
don't change too much about it looks
like the storyline stays the same
and
i can't freaking wait oh yeah connie
britton that's how you know something's
gonna be good when homegirl is there
playing someone's mom connie britton
national treasure she's in it if you
haven't read the book yet i would
recommend reading it before the movie it
comes out because we don't know if the
movie's gonna be good or not so don't
ruin the storyline for yourself on uh on
a risk
read the book get the
enjoy the story even though any time
i've purposely read a book before
watching a movie because i knew a movie
or show was coming out i'd never really
enjoyed either but the book holds up
the book holds up and that was a really
exciting to get on a tuesday after a
labor day you know yeah and the guy who
plays her fiance is so perfectly cast
and you know he's from the big short i
think he's the one who actually coined
the phrase in that movie one plus one
equals sock oh and the stocks were not
adding up
he's also like from a commercial i think
like progressive like he's like a
classic guy from one of those
commercials yeah he's a classic guy
perfect cast yeah oh that's so funny one
plus one equals sock now the movie's
just even more culturally relevant
and you'd love to see it you do
so we've got a great show it's tuesday
which means just business as usual which
is good because we need time to chit
chat you know girly girl chit chat
plus house of the dragon recap
oh yes um okay i'll save it because
literally never have i been more
confused in my whole life okay hopefully
i can answer some questions but i don't
know [ __ ] about [ __ ] either but it was
extremely confusing
okay well chat i'm i'm curious to hear
your thoughts well girly girl chit chat
we'll circle back to that recap but
without further ado
how's you by the way did he have a good
holiday weekend he did of course he was
at his grands at my in-laws he loves it
there more than he loves it at my house
definitely depressed when he got home
but his spirits were lifted because this
morning he went on a walk with butters
and butters had been m.i.a
butters had been m.i.a while butters
wasn't here to pick up theo um i get a
little email after theo's walk like theo
did great he did his business went to
the park and then it said with butters
so i was like whew the gang is getting
better together don't butters was on
vacation don't tell bryce that's last
thing he needs
i won't i won't i would never okay glad
for that update without further ado it
is time for the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
draftkings sportsbook football fans the
first sunday of the nfl season is here
and draftking sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the nfl is
giving new customers a can't miss offer
to celebrate the return of the nfl
season
right now new customers can bet just
five dollars and get two hundred dollars
in free bets instantly and as an added
bonus for week 1 everyone can experience
the thrill of draftkings early win
promotion it's simple bet on an nfl team
to win if your team leads by 10 at any
point during the game you get paid
instantly even if your team loses
download the draftkings sportsbook app
now and use promo code toast to get 200
in free bets instantly when you place a
5 bet this sunday that's code toast only
at draftkings sportsbook an official
sports betting app partner of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
um
i was just reminded of something hold on
what in that ad made me want to tell you
something sports
know what that means chili season
chili season if you haven't seen our new
tick tock and reels go look at it it's
pretty much all the time it's actually
not even all the time it's probably half
the time as we talked about making the
chili and if you're looking for
something to do this week how to fall
into fall i would recommend making a
chili but that's just me
no i woke up today and i was like oh my
god is it a chilly day because not only
is it officially you know not summer
anymore it's the day after labor day
it's also raining and like i don't know
if you can see the window behind me it's
like like literally pitch black outside
it's a [ __ ] chilly day
wow it's not a chilly day here i feel
like not till october will it be a day
of chili
but i do look forward to it whenever it
comes
that's so exciting like obviously a lot
of people are sad the summer is over i
get it personally i'm not i like i find
summer obviously like the shorts of it
all to be really stressful the sweating
all that i also find like the incessant
need to like have something planned on
the weekend to be extremely stressful
like normalize staying at home you know
i just hate that [ __ ] in new york it's
really bad it's like are you going to
talk this weekend are you going to
newport yeah no i want to stay home
[ __ ] i work really [ __ ] hard like
i'm tired yeah
so i'm like looking forward to everyone
being like oh you want to go to dinner
this weekend like something normal not
like want to take a trip or like go to
the bar watch the game on a sunday and
then it's like
oh
sunday night
oh sunday night
staying on the floor gotcha beats stop
cracking real good feelings
it's literally the song that never ends
that's the song like conjunction
junction it's just like yeah
that's something sunday night about to
happen it just moves right through you
it's sticky shoes i feel like elvis with
my legs
watch out
um okay now i guess we could get into
the first story which is uh two fold the
nietzsche film festival
i don't know if it started this weekend
but people started to care this weekend
and florence pugh joined the cast of
don't worry worry darling on the red
carpet including olivia wilde and for
the first time we got to know who's in
this movie and it's star studded aside
from flow miss blow and harry
and shaya shaya shaya's replacement
harry right so not only are they in it
but so is gemma chan nick
chris pine
okay before i dive into like obviously
the people that like everyone cares
about more i'm more interested in the
supplemental characters to this story
okay first of all gemma chan is such an
elegant [ __ ] queen the fact that
she's being like dragged into this is
like kind of disgraceful and just like
watching all the footage seeing the
pictures of her just being like ugh like
what like the fact that she's been kind
of brought down by this scandal like i
feel for her she's too
elegant she's too queeny for this she's
too queeny for this and the fact that
she's in a movie and it's like we're not
even talking about her
disgraceful work that's not gonna work
the second thing i wanted to talk about
is chris pine okay chris pine looked so
[ __ ] handsome like i guess i haven't
like checked in on chris pine in the
last seriously five years because like
the other chris is just kind of
they took over you know evans hemsworth
so i kind of forgot about chris pine
pratt but chris pines like has aged so
beautifully like that hair was stunning
it's like a little salt and pepper it's
nice and long now he was wearing this
extremely kind of stylish
old-school brown outfit it was gorgeous
like i was kind of obsessed with chris
pine when i feel like of all the chris's
at least for me personally like i just
kind of he was never it for me
i i really love him i feel like he's
been in so many projects that are so
good he kind of does like more lowbrow
stuff compared to the other christmas at
this point
um i agree i like the look because i
feel like up until now we couldn't
really tell them all apart and at least
like now he's the blonde chris who's
wearing snitch's jacus pants right right
right and like being one of the male
leads against harry styles who's like
consistently the most best-dressed man
in hollywood like it has to be
frustrating and i'm sure his stylist you
know was met with quite the challenge
and boy did she rise she rise and she
rose and he looked great she rose and
groaned speaking of harry's style though
he looked amazing one of my favorite
outfits of his same it's giving elton
john it's giving austin powers it was oh
it's like beatles for me
oh yeah same thing old and british
literally we said the same thing old and
british yeah and that's my favorite vibe
of all and then i want to talk about
nick kroll who like i feel like it's
such a random celebrity at least to me i
think like a lot of guys like would
consider him like their favorite
comedian and like you know think about
him a lot personally like i've literally
never seen anything he's been in like i
know he does some stand up i know he
does big mouth that cartoon show that
ben [ __ ] loves on the kiki palmers
and maybe i should watch um but i really
have like limited nick crawl knowledge
like he's just kind of this ambiguous
celebrity for me like i think he's also
a podcaster you know like i'm just i'm
confused um but the way i'm
obsessed now like first of all he looked
so handsome like he's definitely gotten
like really handsome in the last couple
of years and then also watching a lot of
the footage of the actual movie premiere
and then the carpet it's clear that like
he's like a safe person for miss flow i
feel like he's the glue holding this
movie cast together
i feel like he's the only one that like
flo opens up to and like they obviously
i think really connected and this is
just from reading body language and
honestly never in my life have i been
even remotely interested in hearing what
a body language expert has to say
because i think most of the time they
literally make that [ __ ] up in like
magazines and on e-news yeah however
i would love the world's premiere body
language expert to do a full like minute
breakdown video
on these people because the vibe that i
got was that like flo really only feels
comfortable
with this group because i imagine that
like
obviously she can't talk to harry or
olivia because they're a team she would
feel ganged up on
gemma chan is not getting involved she's
like leave me out she's above
crap chris pine is like the seasoned
older he's like he's not going to get
involved in the nitty-gritty he's going
to be nice to everyone and do his job
keep his head down
um and that leaves nick crowell and i
think he's like this funny guy i kind of
like ship you know she is no longer with
zach braff i'm new to the nick kroll
fandom so i don't even know if he has a
girlfriend or anything but i kind of
ship him and miss flow i ship chris pine
and miss flow and did you see chris pine
taking those pictures of miss flo
supporting her like helping her get the
content yeah that's where my heart goes
but i'll be fine with either i think
once
this is a wrap i don't think she wants
anything to do with any of these people
no but i do think like she might have
forged a friendship with nick kroll like
i really believe a friendship for life
yeah like you never forget the people
who are there for you and flo seems very
down to earth like she doesn't seem like
a big diva
yeah because she's really
doing a great job an artist of doing
like what she needs to do to promote the
movie she didn't do the panel which good
for her because it looked [ __ ] boring
as [ __ ] considering what we're all
talking about olivia refuses to nourish
the internet oh okay so let's talk about
that obviously they did this press
conference and of course somebody asked
a question like
miss flow is not here the video yada
yada and she gave like literally not
only the most like
well rehearsed but kind of like
condescending answer just basically
saying like the internet and the tabloid
culture like it feeds itself so i don't
feel the need to contribute and while
that is like a general statement on
tabloid culture for sure this is not
tabloid culture literally shia labeouf
sent in a video of you like it's like
it's literally happening in front of our
eyes so just to dismiss it as if it's
like rumors you know like jayla jennifer
aniston and ben brad pitt getting back
together like it's so like dismissive
and not at all indicative of what
actually went down yeah
and the rest of the press conference
looked like a snooze fest so
because miss flow wasn't there and
anything without her is snooze worthy
and then another reporter tried to ask a
question and it's clear like they were
bound and then some women like jumped in
we answered the question olivia's honor
right it was so beyond painful to watch
everyone yeah and there's so many clips
like that have gone viral have you seen
the one of like harry answering a
question and i love harry but he
answered it in the most dominant
i didn't take him for a word salad kind
of guy i took him for like a meaningful
artist smith yeah no like only gives us
a few words and they mean something
they're powerful
so he literally
load of nonsense he was answering a
question about what he liked about the
movie and he was like what i like about
the movie is that it's it's a real
movie
and chris pine who's literally been
acting for 30 years is sitting next to
him like
what
literally what he's like it's like a
movie that you see in the theater yeah
it's like a film you know like one of
the films that you watch in harry's
defense he did then say like i don't
really know if that was an answer it was
kind of just like words but whatever he
said that yes so he at least
acknowledged the moronic thing that came
out of his mouth i think it's probably
very hard for everyone specifically
harry and olivia to be doing their jobs
to the best of their ability right now
because nobody cares really about what
they have to say about the movie like we
want to know the details and
there's so many like people talking
about olivia and harry because they
literally did not touch look at each
other during the entire evening whether
it was on the red carpet at the premiere
so a lot of people think they broke up a
lot of people think that like they don't
want
first of all even though we know a lot
about them they're actually not a public
couple they've never walked a red carpet
together
harry's just so famous that anyone he
dates becomes like fodder for
conversation even though he's not really
living a public relationship it just
feels that way because because we know
everything yes but also she goes to his
shows and i think yeah that's been the
key
yes that's what i was thinking this
morning like that's literally um like
the most public thing that they do and
it's like kind of crazy that she's like
literally on a whirlwind tour yeah but
no they didn't speak to each other
didn't look at each other i think
they're together but didn't want their
relationship to overshadow the movie
and also like
i think it would do more to like
undermine her as a director and give
guidance to this thing about like you
know her not taking the job seriously if
she uses this premiere to show up and
make a statement about her relationship
as opposed to the work personally i
don't think it would have done that but
i could see how she might think that and
not want to just give any more fuel to
like to this is not about the movie
yes i completely agree with what you
said i will say um i thought olivia
looked gorgeous like that yellow dress
like i just need you know yeah no she
did look really gorgeous and then the
other moment that everyone's talking
about is harry styles potentially
allegedly spitting on chris pine as he
took his seat for the movie
so this is why i need a body language
expert like this clip has gone viral it
really does look like harry like juts
out his chin before sitting down next to
chris pine and like
then chris pine looks at his leg where
allegedly the spit may have fallen and
he's like dumbfounded and then they
never make eye contact like is there
beef now between chris pine and harry
styles i don't know okay this is my
theory i think that like
harry styles and chris pine have some
sort of prankster relationship with one
another maybe it's the sort of pranks
where they spit on each other at
inopportune times obviously chris never
thought he would do that as the world's
eyes are on them but harry had a loogie
hooked up and ready to go and chris pine
obviously can't react because but i
think that i think it's a prank i think
that's what pranksters do
i i could see it being a jovial moment
between two male counterparts
see harry getting like so seriously
thank you thank you because he
chris pine can't react i think he spat
on him as a prank i think they spit on
each other back and forth as pranksters
do
the way that i feel like this is one of
the most historic moments in pop cult
like i think in like years from now we
will look at this like because there's
always drama between cast mates and
maybe there's whispers that like two
leads don't like each other but we've
never really had like this level of like
expose everything on a cast
evidentiary support former employees
coming forward with videos and
screenshots and text messages like
this is like
so crazy yeah like the magnitude of it
is not lost on me right and i think they
tried so hard to put it to pretend
and i don't think they could have done a
worse job the fact that there had to be
a buffer in between olivia and harry and
harry and miss flow like gemma and chris
pine were constantly just like
it's so bizarre
and really the takeaway for me is
justice for gemma
it's it ain't right
it ain't right
she is literally like the world's
leading international movie star like
leave her alone yeah so do you are gonna
see the movie
that's the thing it's like no press is
bad press like everyone's talking about
don't worry darling and while my
interest in this saga has peaked to a
level i never expected i like literally
couldn't care less about seeing the
movie isn't that crazy i just want to
know
if it's good
then all of this is really a shame that
it's distracting but i do think it's
also giving press
i just want to know like what are we
fighting for
no and for me like one thing i never
expected was that like the girl who
played the bartender on the oc to become
like one of the film industry's leading
female directors like i just didn't see
that right like people direct movies all
the time a lot
a lot of actors like go into directing
like
and she's just like at venice film
festival
right no because like i think the fact
that she was able to finance this movie
as a female director get harry style
like it's it's a huge accomplishment for
women in directing yes and also i don't
know how many other movies she's done
before this but she did book smart which
was so critically explained so she's a
really good track record
yeah and so she's on this path to
becoming like one of the
best and most critically acclaimed
female directors of our time and the way
that this scandal i think has really
affected that
is not good
yeah because also not only is there
scandal but there's accusations of her
not being
a good director present director
professional and
not protecting her female leads and it's
like that's what this whole time's up
movement that's what the whole um
women in directing kind of um
energy is for it's like
obviously women deserve more
opportunities but then they're also in
charge and they're going to protect
their female actors like it was you know
rumored that she was having shia labeouf
and florence pew like in these very
there's a lot of really intimate scenes
in the film and there was no intimacy
coordinator like your female director
should be protecting your female lead
and so it's like this was supposed to be
this amazing thing for women and she was
gonna start getting these big movie
budgets and protecting women and times
up and here she is like being a part of
the problem yeah
it's so so beyond disappointing like
it's beyond it all comes back to the
intimacy coordinator
jackie exactly and you continue
to make the case
and to persuade i'm convinced but you
continue to convince me every day
that intimacy coordinators are so
necessary
and to the fact that like a female-led
film didn't want like it's
there's no hope it's disappointing it's
a perfect word there's literally no hope
for like hollywood honestly if even like
no there's there's no hope for hollywood
yeah like it's just it's beyond moronic
i've enjoyed this saga immensely i
cannot wait to see what happens next
it's juicier than the drama in the film
honestly it really is and i spoke too
soon because there is one hope for
hollywood and brendan fraser and it's
venice film festival
subset b brendan fraser receives a
standing ovation and has moved to tears
at the venice film festival after he
received six minutes of praise for his
new movie the whale
which um in which he plays a morbidly
obese man have you seen photos he's
wearing like prosthetics
and i don't know the plot but i that's i
didn't want to read more oh i know the
plot
do you like to tell you it's very basic
okay tell me um so he is morbidly obese
he is gay
and his partner like the love of his
life passes away and now he's trying to
reconnect with you know his daughter
from really like a former life who
hasn't spoken to who's sadie sink
who looked oh my god oh my god the way i
would take a bullet first
okay
hollywood has two hopes
two oh sorry three kiki palmer
three hopes oh kelly clarkson oh kelly
clarkson okay but that's it
no more help
um
the way i'm so moved by this story one
because
i've been following this brendan fraser
saga for a while um and i've through
this story uh that happened yesterday
this video went viral the movie ends the
rock posted the video everyone is being
like love brendan fraser so happy for
him nobody has worked harder for longer
i'm literally i'm i'm like literally
going to cry um
and i didn't really even realize why
so much of the interest in brendan
fraser brendan fraser peaked because
brennan fraser for a really long time
was like the it man of hollywood like he
was in george of the jungle like he was
literally
bedazzled could not
make a bad film like he was the
the star
um and then like kind of quickly things
changed for him and i think a lot of
people forgot about him and then there
was like this resurgence whatever
happened to brendan fraser and i didn't
even know but that brendan fraser has
spoken out about um the fact that he was
groped by the president of the hollywood
farm press association and he spoke out
about it and a lot of people believe
he's been blackballed because of it so
this comeback is obviously
layered mostly because like against all
odds like he spoke up against like this
powerful hollywood foreign press
association and
he's been given kind of like a second
chance
one through the internet like i think
the internet really rallied around him
and to through darren aronofsky tara
navanoski said this movie took him 10
years to get made because he could not
cast it like he looked at everyone like
and obviously there's backlash because
he's morbidly obese and they didn't use
a morbidly obese actor or whatever
but he was so hell-bent on finding the
right actor that it took him so long
until he landed on brendan frazier so
it's just this like amalgamation of
amazing things for brendan fraser and
like i'm so overjoyed i'm so emotional
about it too like i love brendan fraser
i would take a bullet several several
wow i didn't know some of that
i didn't know about that thing either
even
more
sweet
more kind of full circle more it's like
justice it's justice yeah and like i
don't know meaningful because even like
the cast of don't worry darling got a
standing ovation i think you know people
in venice just like to stand and clap
thank you literally thank you like i
honestly thank you
thank you because we have taken standing
ovations to another level even me by the
way like when i finish a show i'm like
thank you everyone stand and dance with
me and ben's like you out of standing
ovation like it doesn't really count
because i asked them too right but feel
free by the way if you're coming to see
one of my shows
tour i'm standing at the end is beyond
mandatory okay just act like you're in
bed like everyone gets a standing
ovation now in general like a concert of
course you stand and clap at the end
what are you a monster you're right it's
the appropriate thing to do but
something about these videos not the
brandon frazier one of just people
having watched a movie and crying and
clapping like no i know
it's like staged no it's just like it's
a movie they
were pretending but this one feels
different with brent and frazier i'm not
talking about brendan fraser i know they
weren't even clapping for the movie they
were clubbing for the man i can respect
clapping for a man but to clap like that
so emotional for a movie
it's like like unless it's the greatest
showman sit the [ __ ] down no seriously
like unless it's like schindler's list
like it's just a movie yeah
and i don't know much about the whale i
don't know if it's based on a true story
but the way i'm dying to see this movie
even though i know it's gonna absolutely
destroy me
i cannot wait yes and now of course
it's giving there's buzz that i just
created oscar oscar it makes you think
okay it's a one-man movie he has a
standing ovation
he's playing a per like you know he's
he's carrying the film it's daryn
arnofsky
if brendan fraser wins an oscar like
i'm gonna make a promise right now
no okay ready if brendan frazier doesn't
win the
oscar
i'm gonna get
a bob
okay
so i'm personally campaigning for harry
styles to win for don't worry darling
he's not going to like that's my
personal he's not because you need to um
no i know but
is uh academy awards is that the
hollywood farm press yes right
is the president who he
spoke out against still the president
like it's probably it might be very
difficult for him
unless there's been a total changing of
the guard no problem
hfpa is the golden globes oh okay but
that's really why i just think like
hollywood is so bullshittery like
the way like they all rallied around
times up and got us all like galvanized
and it's like you are the ones who have
to change not us you know but there's
always you can't even do anything there
was times up on time's up and corruption
there
right and like
i felt like everyone was like we got
harvey it's over and it's like did you
mean harvey's there are and aren't even
that famous so like no one's talking
about them but they're just as powerful
but also just as powerful harvey's i'm
sure and all the people who protect
harvey's
right so it's like that now in hindsight
like while it felt so nice at the time
and it was like finally like we're going
now it's like
really like everything that still comes
out it's just it was giving low energy
it was giving nothing yeah
so um i really hope that we can continue
to protect brendan fraser at all costs
like the way i see a picture of him and
i want to start hysterically crying is
not [ __ ] normal i love this man
i love this man
this man i love
love i mean this
love this aye man okay well now we can
put our energy towards bread and persian
marine oscar that was in english bread
abrasion brendan fraser winning an oscar
and that will get us excited about the
oscars something that is so hard to
muster up excitement for these days like
the last oscars couldn't catch me caring
about one movie not a minute none not
one
none of the above i don't think zero i
don't think i saw oh no we saw eyes of
tammy faye and we saw i saw a house of
gucci but still i really don't care
yeah no i love tammy faye though in the
words of demi lovato and cheryl lloyd i
really don't care
wow niche reference came up on my
spotify yesterday because i was
listening to 10 things i hate about you
radio
you have got to be stopped
never i love it i went for a run yes
humble brag and i listen what wait
start over i told you that i just
finished breastfeeding by the way it's
just a little update about me yesterday
that's huge yesterday was the first day
that i didn't pump or nurse
and that's that on that are you leaking
no
wow
that was never my issue oh uh the
opposite you know
right like supply chain crisis
so i'm now putting those efforts towards
working out and eating right i'll let
you know how it goes oh my god how was
the job did you get out of breath i did
no it was great it was great
to move it was a walk slash run you know
depending on the song that came up i
would run for the chorus
take my sweet time but it's also 90
degrees so
no no no like literally i can't run for
15 seconds without literally needing to
go to the hospital yeah but it was ten
things about your radio that got me
through so thanks
artist
leah kate leah kate uh that's what i
thought but i just didn't want to get it
wrong that's okay that would have been
really embarrassing beyond
okay are you ready for our next story
just ready right now you know i'm just
like totally ready great because it's
the story that's going to make you
[ __ ] sick for the day okay
there's always one
tiffany haddish is addressing
molestation allegations quote i know
people have questions okay so
let's start from the beginning a lawsuit
was followed against tiffany haddish and
fellow comedian
um
ari spears ari spears accusing them of
molestation by jane doe and john doe a
brother and sister who are anonymously
suicidal minors two comedians one of
them is now um
14 years old the the boy john doe and
the girl is 22 years old but these
allegations happened when the girl was
14 and the boy was seven
they said that their mom was a comedian
who met tiffany haddish through the
comedic circle and tiffany and ari
spears put her them in some comedic
sketches that were wildly inappropriate
grooming uh just
awful awful instances there's a whole
article in the daily beast with the
allegations and all of the details
yes so basically they were making some
videos for funny or die
no not for funny or die they posted the
video like funny yeah yeah yeah no like
they made that to post it on funny or
dog okay but
does like a community aspect where it's
not they're not producing no because
like don't drag them into this because
they are not
no so what's interesting is that like
they posted their own user generated
content on funny or die i guess in hopes
to you know go viral create some sort of
traction and it was removed immediately
buy funny or die they were like this is
user-generated content it has nothing to
do with us once it was put up it was
flagged immediately and removed
immediately like it's disgusting so this
was not like um
like at the time people thought it was
[ __ ] weird too yeah so the girl was
in a sketch where she's like uh
eating a sub and they wanted to be like
fellatio asked you know she's a 14 year
old girl like it was giving like dan
schneider it was yes and then the boy
who was seven years old was
in a sketch called through the eyes of a
pedophile and
um
they're zoomed in it's so
it's so nauseating
they're like this is so disgusting on
his
um
stop okay okay read the article for
yourself
[ __ ] nauseating
[Music]
awful oh and now tiffany haddish is
responding
because the lawsuit is now out there
with all the details she said i know
people have a bunch of questions i get
it i'm right there with you
unfortunately because there's an ongoing
legal case there's very little that i
can say right now okay erica jane with
the
i hate when people say that even though
it is true like it's annoying but
clearly while this sketch was intended
to be comedic it wasn't funny at all and
i deeply regret having agreed to act in
it i really look forward to being able
to share a lot more about this situation
as soon as i can
so this guy ari spears who i'd really
not heard of until literally a week ago
um was recently just getting you know uh
in the news because he's been saying
like really [ __ ] gross disgusting
things about lizzo
um so this guy is just like obviously
gross
i never in my life expect when i saw
this headline i was like
what
tiffany haddish grooming i was like
there it was so shocking to me and the
statement from
their attorneys and ari spears was you
know this is a shakedown these uh
plaintiffs have went to lawyers all
throughout town trying to get them to
take on our case to shake us down for
money it's so disgusting and
condescending i'm so i could i feel like
vomiting from this story like it's
it's wild and it's so disgusting and
it's like what is with people and kids
what is what what is with everyone being
a [ __ ] pedophile or being like
fine with pedophile like oh like
pedophilia humor no
no it's so weird like it's becoming like
so common like every actor has some sort
of like pedophilia drama like that's not
normal no it's not normal
it's like it's minor attracted persons
like i can't
the the de-stigmatization of pedophilia
like i'm not here for it we need to
re-stigma re-stimulate we need to
increase the stigma turn it into our
state crank it up yeah it's [ __ ]
weird yeah and it's just becoming like
commonplace like i read all metaphilia
what
we are not protecting the kids like it's
really making me upset it's disgusting
it's disgusting we're not protecting the
kids
uh
as taylor armstrong would say enough
enough yeah
what's so weird is i have a
stack of books here that i rest my
computer on and tiffany haddish's book
is in there
did you read it no i didn't i actually
look at it every day and i was thinking
about reading it no name
no thanks i'm tossing it i can't look at
it every day i only have icons only
claudia girl with no job
do you need more copies yeah
i want a whole shelf in my house you got
it it's actually like really not that
iconic i should switch them out
like the other books because you're
you're with a like a bunch of losers and
pedophiles a legend
um okay i can move on from the
pedophilia honestly it's like not the
vibe no it's not the vibe but you know
what is the vibe our next story because
jennifer lawrence is opening up about
what it's like being a new mama and
she's sharing the details
thankfully kylie take notes
so we got a name and a gender
jennifer lawrence is on the cover of
vogue for october
and the new york post wants me to
subscribe to post sports it's not gonna
happen
okay she's on the cover of vote she's
revealing the name and sex of her
six-month-old baby jennifer lawrence
revealed her six-month-old child's name
and sex on tuesday telling vogue in her
october 2022 cover story that she gave
birth to a baby boy in february the
little ones moniker was inspired by one
of her husband cook moroni's favorite
artist sai twombly so her bebe's name is
sai hold on spelled c y
it's a really cute name um
just
everything jennifer lawrence does is so
[ __ ] elegant like
oh just
oh i want to tell somebody the name of
my child put it in vogue yeah like oh
come on
right oh the cover sure i could pencil
it in like it's so she's so classy
and i [ __ ] love this [ __ ] i love
this [ __ ]
she's so
she's the definition of everything of
the sort and she's darren arnofsky girly
yes what was she in darren iron off mom
yeah
yeah and she's you know there's a lot of
um info she's really opening up in this
article and i guess if you're jennifer
lawrence like you're only going to open
up for vogue she doesn't just put it on
the gram talking about how motherhood
has changed her her love for babies now
how she never thought she could love her
baby like more than she loves her cat
she thought like maybe i'll look
relatable she was like maybe i'll love
him as much as i love my cat but no
she's that whole new woman she said she
this could you know potentially affect
like the roles that she takes from now
on like being from a new mama
perspective which of course that makes
everything
you know i feel like when you have a
when you become a parent like everything
you contribute to the world like you
want it to be like safe and positive and
fun and light it just changes your
perspective on everything it's wild no
your perspective is literally like
changed change is yours not being like a
now an auntie of two
not really um
maybe i don't love my nibblings that
much
if you don't want to change the world
for them
um and i just think it's crazy like we
still don't know kylie's baby's name
like that's what i find interesting from
this story you know what i find
interesting about that piece is that i'm
at peace with it
like i don't ever need to know her
baby's name i don't ever need to like
see her baby i'm okay with that maybe
that's my new mama perspective though
maybe and what's crazy is actually
before i gave birth i was like where's
the name right i didn't i don't think
i don't think i'm at peace i think i
just don't care anymore like it's been
too long you can only care about
something for so long without getting
anything in return like i can't keep
caring yeah i just like don't feel
curious and maybe now i actually am a
little more curious about chloe's baby
name
yes well chloe still has time you know
she's a new new mama she has time
curious time time
getting me open and leaving me back
and it's cool baby with me
you know when you start singing a song
and literally what song is that wait let
me think
you
don't know just so pretty to think
all along oh yeah taylor swift it's just
funny how like literally lyrics are
ingrained in my brain and sometimes i
don't even know what song there but i'm
singing it like i knowing every word
agreed same but you didn't even know it
was taylor
no i literally was like is this casey
mustard it's harry styles luke homes i
knew it was taylor
baby with me oh my god so do you know
like that's invisible string by taylor
do you know like the swifty theory on
that i saw something but i forget
that like literally like they just make
fun of the fact that like pretty much in
the whole song she's calling joe alwyn
poor yes okay that's what i saw like i
didn't used to have a job at the ice
cream shop
i didn't click the link
it's so funny every time i see them i
send them to snitch it's literally it
makes me laugh so much just because like
in a couple times in the song she says
things like oh you used to work at the
ice cream shop like for some extra money
like normal things people did but you
know taylor grew up like in a mansion
so it's like
if you listen to the song through the
perspective of like her calling her
boyfriend poor like it's actually so
funny
okay green was the color of the grass
where i used to read at centennial park
i used to think i would meet somebody
there teal was the color of your shirt
when you were 16 at the yogurt shop you
used to work at
to make make a little money
time curious time gave me no compasses
gave me no signs were the clues where
were there clues i didn't see and isn't
it just so pretty to think all along
there was some invisible string tying
you to me okay just a yogurt chop
i think there's one more in the bad was
the
bad was the blood of the song in the cab
on your first trip to l.a love is
self-reference
okay yeah but it's like he took a cab
you know
like if you just like if you really
stretch and like read the song through
the perspective like she's money shaming
you ate at my favorite spot for dinner
bold was the waitress on our three-year
trip getting lunch bouncing oh yes and
then it's like they go down to the lakes
for lunch and like obviously she's rich
and famous like the waitress knows her
but not him she said i looked like an
american singer time mystical time
cutting me open then healing me fine
were there clues i didn't see and isn't
it just so pretty to think all alone
there was some invisible string a string
that pulled me out of all the wrong arms
right into that
dive bar
something
dive bar cheap [ __ ]
isn't it funny and i'm sure like not at
all is that what she meant but it's
actually funny like taylor your
privilege is showing
something wrapped all of my past
mistakes in barbed wire chains around my
demons wool to brave the seasons one
single thread of gold tied me to you
gold that she purchased not him don't
get a twist it was only one
single and it wasn't even 18 counts he
couldn't go for two
i just think that that sometimes the
swifties are crazy but that is [ __ ]
funny that is funny
great i'm glad that we explored that
also before we move on not to ruin the
jennifer lawrence cover but um it is
flawed
because on the cover um there's an essay
called marilyn and me by lena dunham
so well that's so classically to jenna
me and ben started a show have you heard
of industry yes
me and ben watch the first episode when
i tell you i've never had worse anxiety
watching a show it is so
oh my god i can't do that pit inducing
so we liked it but we were also like why
are we putting our mental health at risk
just to watch this dumb show um and
literally the first episode ended and it
says directed by lena dunham
so we didn't watch that's so crazy i see
so many commercials for industry and
they never tell you that it's directed
by lena dunham
i don't think they want to lead people
to know no
was it good
i mean yes but no like it was very
harrowing yeah like just these young
kids will do anything to be successful
like it was really really it was
upsetting
i feel like like you might like it
though no i don't like shows that give
you anxiety like that like
unless we're you're taking me to another
realm
yeah totally i i hate shows that like
really like make me feel actual anxiety
for the characters it's like i have
enough problems in my own life yeah like
the house of the dragon i feel it all
day long on behalf right because it's
like not real at all right exactly
and the way
i take a bullet for that damon boy
we're almost there one more story can
you okay can you wait with your bullets
is it the story that's brought to you by
jenny kane it is
new season is upon us it's chilly season
and it's a great time to bring a new
point of view into every room in your
home so as you guys know i've been
sharing on my instagram i'm totally
refreshing my home not like a crazy
overhaul but like new pieces
like small things like candles big
things like blankets
furniture chairs um and jenny kane is
the perfect place to start if you're
looking for a refresh some of their most
iconic and signature pieces are the
vista collection it's their most
anticipated home launch which is
inspired by the best of california
design you can make the most of every
outdoor moment it's designed for a
season spent alfresco pre-ordered today
to prepare for your best summer yet if
you weren't happy with the vibes that
were accumulated this summer start now
because jenny cain's new collection is
highly anticipated it'll all be ready by
next summer and you still
can get a great deal they also have the
miramar collection which is a versatile
linen suited to everywhere from the
bedroom to your living room and any
piece in the collection is destined to
be treasured for years to come that one
is in stock and ready to ship your dream
is going to await you and take advantage
of it being in stock as you guys know
supply chain is real
so many of uh furniture companies have
major delays but they are in stock which
is premium and very rare and they also
have the pacific bed which comes in
linen and buckle also known as boucle
you can find the
finding the perfect bed can be tough
because you want it to be elevated but
you also want it to endure be strong
and the pacific bed comes in classic
colors and timeless fabrics that work
with any bedroom style it is a piece
that you will enjoy for years to come
jenny kane home creates california
inspired classics for any room or mood
they're grounded in natural textures
inviting neutrals and they're the pieces
that you'll love coming home to check
out the jenny kane home membership to
experience the best of jenny kane home
for just 150 annually
you can get insider only perks that get
you one step closer to your dream space
and discount on furniture you can get 20
off all furniture and home decor free
shipping on furniture and early product
access and much more with the jenny kane
home membership you can join at
jennycaine.com
membership or go to jennycane.com home
to create the space you'll never want to
leave again that's jennycaine.com
home to create the space you'll never
want to leave and jennycain.com
membership to check out that membership
pricing and jenny kane is spelled
j-e-n-n-i-k-a-y-n-e
dot com slash home great thank you so
much mcclardia
you're welcome
what can i say except yeah
yeah just a joke from my instagram that
i posted last night check it out give it
a like oh you know somebody left a
comment that really made me think i
think about this a lot sometimes since
like we're constantly growing like
literally the biggest podcast on the
planet someone was like you girlies just
say stuff without context all the time
like who are these people you're talking
about and so i would feel weird being
like you know
ben and i my husband
but like i do think sometimes we need to
be a little bit more contextualized okay
like what
i don't know but the girl was like i
literally never know who you're talking
about oh okay we'll have to do a
refresher but like at the top of an
episode but here's just the bear basics
ben is claudia's husband zach is my
husband theo's claudia's dog bruno is my
dog we call them brazen strassen brass
any variation bruce bryce bryson that's
bruno rice thrice theo dora theodora
that's the crunchy um when i say without
further ado
how's do i'm talking about theo because
we call him
theodora that's why that's that jackie's
son is rolled slash rodini harry even
though he's really just rolled now yeah
it's harry's house that i live in um
claudia calls him rolled and then our
sister when we say snitch that's our
youngest sister margo she hosts a
podcast on her network called this
called the snapchat so when you say
margaret and i went to turks and caicos
and then i'm over here i say the
snatcher and i go like that it's just
because she's a snatchler
right our older sister her name is
olivia her daughter's name is michaela
but she goes by taylor taylor swift her
royal canis kaylor
and claudia is mccleardia um named after
emily ratakowski's ex-husband sebastian
mcclurd
i like that one mcclellania
mcclurdia
and now it's time for our fifth and
finals story now that we just covered
all of that
um spencer pratt claims lisa kudrow told
heidi mountain that he has the eyes of a
serial killer
spencer pratt doubled down on his claim
that lisa kudrow is one of the worst
humans he's ever met the hills alum
continued stirring the pot with a new
video shared to tiktok on saturday in
which he detailed an alleged
conversation between lisa kudrow and his
wife heidi montag he said the year was
2009 and heidi and i were invited to our
first elite a-list party it was clear
when we got there no one wanted us to be
there
he said um it was almost like we were
filming for punk and the camera was
going to pop up but heidi and i didn't
care as there was delicious food in an
open bar as we were sitting there
consuming a little caviar phoebe
approaches with a little sh which was a
little shocking as no one had spoken to
us at all at the party he then alleged
that the star proceeded to tell his wife
heidi that quote she needs to get away
from me as fast as possible because i'm
going to murder her and that he had the
eyes of a serial killer according to
spencer heidi waited to see if it was a
joke before realizing that it clearly
wasn't
quote maybe this is a bit a skit maybe
this is a hidden camera party and why we
were invited to this elite party but no
one laughs she just walks away and that
right there was the rudest moment i've
ever encountered with a human being
right so somebody asked on tick tock
like who is the rudest celebrity you've
ever met spencer said lisa kudrow people
were quaking because lisa kudrow is
america's sweetheart phoebe from friends
romeo michelle like she's an icon so
then people were requesting he tell the
story he did it in like three parts of
course like being clickbaity um
and to be honest while i do
feel like you know his feelings might be
valid i do feel like people at the time
like knew heidi and spencer from the
show
they made spencer out to be like such a
villain that he was like literally
taking advantage of heidi and i think in
her own way like lisa kudrow maybe
thought she was helping heidi um not
just being like a a nasty [ __ ]
yeah
i think so i don't really feel like this
this counts as like a story like lisa
kudrow's mean in person you know yeah i
think anybody who watched the show back
then
we weren't like enlightened enough to
realize
how fake it was how much spencer and
haider were putting on
you know if you just watch the show and
it's reality tv you take it at face
value like spencer is not a good guy
right maybe you're really invested in
the show and like you go to heidi and
you try and warn her off this guy who
you think you know him but the point is
that you don't but we did not know that
then
no of course not and so like if an older
woman saw them at a party and like we
were all so enrapt like oh man we have
to get her away from spencer like lisa
couture might have just been watching
the show and then took it upon herself
like once in a lifetime opportunity to
like try and be helpful now knowing what
we know we know like there really wasn't
anything wrong with spencer um they were
you know just villainized for the point
of entertainment so
knowing what we know now it sounds like
a really mean thing to do but at the
time i could see her just thinking it
was the right thing to do
yeah
then because frankel is also saying that
she agrees
you know one thing i did not see on my
bingo card this year is like
the downfall of bethenny frankel why did
bethany agree with spencer would she say
i don't know but she also said she had
like a negative interaction with lisa
coutro and like the way bethany has been
in the news these last couple of weeks
just like getting into petty fights with
other celebrities like she just had this
thing with courtney stodda and courtney
student was like literally you calling
out the kardashians is hilarious because
look at this clip of me on your show i
literally left your show
your talk show back in the day
hysterically crying she literally
bethany was like you came here and said
you don't want to do porn but you have
really huge tits and blonde hair like
you look like a stripper like bethany
was being so condescending to this 19
year old girl it's like and that's what
we were saying like if you're going to
criticize the kardashians you have to
have a perfect image you have to always
be supporting women and always be an
amazing role model for women and bethany
has many examples of her literally doing
the opposite so then bethenny frankel
messaged courtney stodden after courtney
stadt and posted that and literally sent
the most nasty manipulative victim
energy message to courtney starting
courtney staunen then posted the message
like
literally this is what i'm dealing with
and just making bethany look so bad and
it's just one thing after another and
when bethany left housewives like it was
really because she was above housewives
you know like they were just kind of low
brow really drink like alcoholic energy
she was going on shark tank like it
wasn't a good match for her anymore you
know what now it's a good match because
everything bethany has done in the last
like year is really um
like bringing her down to a level like
that is housewives
what what did the message say
i'll read it to you it was so [ __ ]
rude ready yeah
and like then people commenting um
about their experiences while going on
that show
it's just it's not a good look for
bethany
courtney i can never find her [ __ ]
instagram
bethany
courtney maybe she's shadow band
she definitely is by the way i have to
like search courtney stodd and instagram
on safari like a grandma
okay courtney a stop and ready then
here's the message i just saw your post
i watched the entire interview again as
a woman in business and branding i was
listening to what you said your goals
were to be 19 to not go into porn and to
forge a new path i was supportive of
that choice which you didn't show in any
of your clips perhaps unfortunately how
we present ourselves is part of our
branding and marketing you were
certainly marketing yourself differently
than you are now which seems to be
working for you i wish you luck in your
endeavors if something i said upset or
stuck with you i'm sorry perhaps our
conversation did contribute to the
positive path that you embarked on i do
think about young women very much as a
mother and i believe that you changed
your course and direction that's
inspirational so not only is she saying
like you were responsible for the way
people treated you because you branded
and marketed yourself like a [ __ ]
because she basically dressed
differently she's also saying oh i i
shoved you in the right direction look
look what happened to you maybe it's
because of the conversation we had which
is [ __ ] delusional narcissistic
behavior
and
if something i said upset you i'm sorry
that's like not an apology yeah
so it's like she's getting into fights
she's like bring i don't know what
happened like
in bethany's career i just didn't see
this sort of fall from grace for her
every time she's in the tablet she's
talking now about meghan markle she's
talking about the kardashians it's
courtney stodd and it's like
it's giving like perez hilton energy
yeah but i mean i think it all has not
all has to do but she has a podcast now
and yeah like that's what
you gotta do is talk and yeah
have some hot takes and these are super
hot and i think she's not very soft
no i know it's just
it's it's do you agree with this
from shark tank to podcast back talker
it's just fall from grace a little okay
okay i'm just like every time i see her
in the news i'm like ugh what now yeah
i'm just trying to understand
but you also say that like her makeup
reviews and stuff like do you remember
yes
and
you have to feed the beast
yes yes yes
personality
yes
which is just a step down from being a
shark
but this is what a digital personality
does
yes very true
so i just believe lisa kudrow's a nice
person honestly like i i'm i'm not
changing my opinion on it yet
yeah i don't have an opinion but this to
me isn't like so damning i agree with
you i could see how she thought she was
doing something good based on what she
saw on tv which at the time i think a
lot of us thought was real
yes and we were like impassioned about
it yeah
so those were the fast five and now
we're gonna dive into tv recap house of
the dragon episode three
um we fast forwarded a little bit three
years into the future obviously
her best friend married her dad they had
two well they have one on the way and
they had one kid and they had a son
aegon which is a big deal because it's a
man and everyone's pretty much waiting
for the dad to be like never mind
renerial disease your brother's the heir
but he's not wavering and rhaenyra is
giving some negative bratty energy even
though her dad literally has not given
up on her yet yeah she's not making it
easy for him and he's trying to stand by
her but
she's just not making it easy he hasn't
like he said that he's standing firm
but
one he does waiver he doesn't know what
he wants he doesn't know what what's
right and so he is really weak in that
sense but i do feel like he's going to
waiver which makes like what he said
last night even worse like worse telling
her he's not gonna because he's
constantly going back on his word as it
pertains to raniera also um was anyone
else like the whole episode just waiting
for him to drop dead like i just i'm
like oh he's gonna die now like he was
when he was a wee drunk at the hunt i
was like i thought that either
something bad was going to happen or
when he went to stab the boar the deer
i thought maybe he would die in a way
like robert baratheon like a little
poisoned wine
someone accidentally kills him turns out
it's not an accident so i like love sir
christian cole he's so hot obviously i'm
shipping him in renera so now that
rainier has been given the blessing to
choose who she's married to and i don't
think that the dad is being unreasonable
he's like no one is going to give you no
one's going to give your claim any sort
of uh
validity so you should make it as strong
as possible like marry a lannister have
a son like so that people are can digest
the idea of you being queen like she's
not helping herself at all no not at all
even he's not above duty
but speaking of him getting remarried
the way i hate that [ __ ] friend like
okay when she was waltzing around the
promenade sending the musician out your
queen commands [ __ ] shut up okay but
like she really could be so much worse i
feel and maybe eventually she'll turn
fully evil i've seen people say that
she's giving like cersei vibes
i think she's being very patient with
rainey or as she should be considering
she was her friend first but it's not
like she's like whispering the king like
bad things about rhaenyra she knows it's
true anytime she has to go to him and
like try and twist his arm it's only
because like her dad her dad were in
that position i don't she's not
innately a bad person i'm sorry
when otto hightower suggested that
ronira marry aegon her two-year-old
brother
[Laughter]
i
literally
died like i'm deceased in heaven right
now like i was like
and i'm just grateful to the king for
having a [ __ ] normal reaction to that
because not only is it disgusting on so
many levels it's just beyond
i think that that was there to make the
idea of rainier and daemon more
palatable because now i'm like well
please it's not her brother
no the way i'm obsessed with rhaenyra
and damon as a couple is okay like it's
so funny because that actor played
prince philip in the show and honestly i
didn't think he was handsome enough to
be prince philip and like he kind of
bothered me um the way i think he's so
[ __ ] hot now and like when he got out
of that cave and i love how like
literally couldn't win the war for three
years oh my brother might come to help
[ __ ] him i'm gonna win today right now
went in
slayed the crabby man and walked out
with the blood on his neck oh my god i
was living for it living you do realize
he didn't say one word the whole episode
he was just acting
now one word from when he got off the
dragon went on his little rowboat
surrendered bought the crab a king eater
not a word
i did not realize that no lines in the
script for him
no words were spoken nowhere no words
needed to be spoken and yet he was the
star like i was obsessed with that even
though my confusion really lied within
the crab area i have literally no idea
like what that was like who are the
crabs and who's that guy like
i think he's like king of the pirates
and he was disrupting their shipping
lanes like stealing their
booty because you could see like by the
caves there was all of this they're like
hoarding stuff yeah
and so they didn't have safe passage for
their ships and the sea snake i think
he's in charge of
this and
snake is auntie's husband and his
husband he's in charge of the swells and
various other shipping ports and then
they wanted renera to marry sea snake's
son who was that guy at the table yep
good match i was into him because his
[ __ ] grandpa or that other guy
uncle was being so negative so negative
oh my god that kind of energy no it's
war we need positive camaraderie if we
all just wallow in self-pity like we're
gonna die right and as the nephew was
saying what have you done to fight the
war the only one who's fighting this war
is damon is damon
no like so obsessed with david i
actually cannot remember a character
even from game of thrones that i've like
been more in love with like because it
really was like jon snow okay yeah for
sure but
i'm obsessed with damon like literally
obsessed obsessed and i really do think
he's meant to be this ambiguous
character i saw this quote going around
i think it's from game of thrones about
how you know the targaryens have had
people who
are to some people a hero and to other
people the villain and i think that he
really toes that line really well but
yeah because he didn't have to beat up
the messenger you know like that was
uncalled for
yeah i just wanna know when he was the
gold cloaks if those people were
actually convicted thieves and rapists
and murderers
no it's a good it's an important
distinction if he was just like walking
around cracking skulls
i did feel like the whole pig thing and
then the white antler was like a little
dumb game of thrones loves that
symbolism and i know we're all feeling
impatient because we want answers
yesterday but never forget that we sat
through eight seasons of game of thrones
how many wolves dire wolves did the
starks have that were
like i was just confused okay so this
boar came out of nowhere and i was like
oh that's the animal they're all looking
for yes does it too
so then i'm like then they see the
antelope and i totally am with rainer
like let him go let him live no that was
okay there's a difference between
hunting as a sport and what the king did
which was
so [ __ ] loser of course and he
couldn't even do it on the first try
so embarrassing that but also
did you notice the king was wearing a
glove the whole time like i do think he
lost the digit
perhaps more than one
yikes
but you know what it's been about four
years since the beginning of the show
and he's still alive
right that's why i was like oh any
minute now drop dead
yeah
the way renera is so stunning like this
actress like she's just gorgeous i know
she really is she's amazing too and when
she walks and she has the same style
like
in spo as danny so when we're like
seeing her walk from the profile it's
just like giving danny across the seven
seas it's giving danny targaryen for
sure yeah
but she's gotta work on her attitude
she's gotta stop fighting with her dad
like
you want him on your side no she is
seventeen 17. she's obviously like a
moody teenager but he's the difference
between you becoming queen and you
becoming a sorry person
yeah and i know he's only two but like i
[ __ ] hate aegon
yeah he's not the vibe like stop i keep
like accidentally seeing like small
spoilers i'm not i'm not going to spoil
anything i don't know what happens but
just like small things that
are annoying i'm not going to spoil
anything either but i did see a spoiler
i believe the one the first one that you
saw about who marries rhaenyra
oh i haven't seen that yeah i think i
did but i think i put it out of my mind
no and like it was in my own messages
from a toaster like that's wrong yeah
i'll tell you why i saw a spoiler
one from twitter but i go looking for i
love people's tweets after the show
they're so [ __ ] funny and sometimes
you get some good like i didn't realize
that damon didn't speak a word i'm not
gonna lie i saw that on twitter oh my
god fraud no but i don't know it i'm
limiting it fraudulent energy you
admitted it 10 minutes later okay but
like i wanted you guys to sink in and
i'll tell you my sources your sources
okay okay
um i once saw a large family not family
tree yeah
tree of
yeah
no robert baratheon ends up on it you
know like
it's not the targaryen family tree it's
the tree of
succession
um
i saw that and then i was looking at a
game of thrones article today on page
six and it said this episode this thing
has spoilers for season three i was like
great i already watched it what could it
be and right there was something that's
going to happen that hasn't happened yet
sort of
right there
and i saw on twitter remember
stannis's daughter who was always
reading
hold on stannis baratheon she was like
robert's
brother he was the war guy you know he
always was with the wrestler he was like
skinny and tall red lady
shadow with the face of stannis
baratheon
yeah but i don't remember his daughter
his daughter she had the red hair she
was like a little girl she had a little
bit of grayscale oh of course and they
killed her
oh my god and they killed her in such a
way in a sacrifice oh my god i forgot
about that that was about that part but
you know she was always reading of
course literary queen
who did she teach to read ben hated her
oh someone who was living
hated her yes somebody who was living
with them like a man um
an important person who needed to read
was it
where were they
the red lady a-a-a-a they were at um
who was with them like they were trying
to win the war
i don't know whatever who the [ __ ] did
she teach to read all right i'll google
it hang on
stannis baratheon daughter teaching
person to read
i never know i got to google
sir davos sir davos yes yes yes
he was jon snow's
yes okay great she taught davos street
thank you anyways at one point she's
talking about what she's reading i saw
like a the quote but i i clicked out
where she's talking about ray nira
because she was reading like the
histories and so i think that if you
were to re-watch game of thrones like
there would be spoilers there's mad
spoilers because it's i love that it's
layered layered george doesn't do it any
other way
no he doesn't
they don't
they don't
he doesn't have two hours in his name
for nothing reads twice
layered ours
um so
game of the throne dragon whatever it's
called what were your questions what
were you confused about
the crabs
oh
just all of the craps
yeah
it was like
the whole thing like who the [ __ ] is
that man why is he wearing a mask was he
burned from the dragons or just like in
general i do think it was previous
yeah me too they look like old wombs
plus he already had the mask
yeah yeah i just like that popped up out
of nowhere it was a little bit stupid
yeah okay cool i'm so glad we're in a
great man but damon prevails
hopefully he can come home sweep raniera
off her feet
wore a hero huh
um and that's our show it's been an hour
and a half i gotta take a piss
so badly i was almost gonna do it before
i have some dragon recap but i was like
i know we have
episodes like for the last two weeks
have all been an hour and a half and i'm
going to get a uti because like
literally every single day i'm holding
in a piece so bad
so let's
keep doing episodes of song we have to
put in a pee break
or we need to just like turn these
booklet chairs into toilets with um a
bedpan underneath love
a a chamber pop a chamber pot
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found south spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heart radio cast box all
the places so if you listen to the
podcast find out someone you toast leave
a 5 star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing tuesday and we'll see
you tomorrow for hump day
bye